bienen können nicht fliegen das haben
mathematiker vor vielen jahren berechnet
doch die natur zeigt dass die
wissenschaft nicht immer recht hat
beziehungsweise etwas hinterherhinkt
denn die fleißigen insekten legen
unglaublich weite strecken im flug
zurück und haben dabei ein ganz
ungewöhnliches muster von flügelschlägen
mit zeitlupen aufnahmen von
hochgeschwindigkeits kameras und einem
flugroboter konnten forschende das
geheimnis des bienenflug lüften aber man
kann selbst den bienenflug im bild
festhalten und dafür gibt es im video
ein goodie klicks um science and future
geht es montags mittwochs und freitags
umfassend recherchierte videos aus den
bereichen umwelt und natur abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
dieses video ist in kooperation mit der
ct fotografie entstanden dem fachmagazin
rund um digitale bilder und am ende
erwartet euch eine kleine überraschung
für foto-fans und durch die
unterstützung von ct fotografie ist
dieses video auch komplett werbefrei
sie sind unverzichtbar für die
biologische vielfalt und gelten
hierzulande sogar als die dritt
wichtigsten nutztiere direkt nach
rindern und schweinen die bieten weil
sie etliche obst gemüse und
futterpflanzen bestäuben tragen die
insekten maßgeblich zur biodiversität
und der ernährung der menschen bei
insgesamt sind rund 80 prozent der
pflanzen auf die bienen angewiesen denn
die bestäubung ist notwendig damit samen
und früchte gebildet werden und die
pflanze sich vermehren kann
aber obwohl sie so wichtig sind gibt es
einen erschreckenden rückgang der bienen
und dass auf der ganzen welt in
deutschland ist bereits die hälfte der
insgesamt etwa 570 wildbienenarten
bedroht und der grund dafür sind wie so
oft wir menschen monokulturen weniger
wilde ursprüngliche natur wie zb wiesen
mit wildblumen und der einsatz von
pestiziden in der landwirtschaft das
sind die gründe für das bienensterben
fachleute befürchten sogar dass einige
bienenarten in wenigen jahren komplett
ausgestorben sein könnten das wird für
uns menschen eine ernsthafte bedrohung
denn mit den bienen müssen wenn nicht
nur auf honig sondern auch auf obst und
gemüse verzichten zumindest werden die
erträge deutlich sinken
eine furchtbare entwicklung wenn man
bedenkt dass diese in st
nicht nur überaus nützlich sondern auch
richtig faszinierend sind bienen haben
einen extrem guten geruchssinn der ist
sogar noch besser als der von hunden
denn sie müssen extrem schnell reagieren
wenn sie im flug auf der suche nach
pollen und nektar sind sie können
winzige duftspuren aufnehmen um
blitzschnell erkennen um welchen duft es
sich handelt und wo er herkommt um die
richtigen blüten zu finden bienen
kommunizieren untereinander mit der
sogenannten tanzsprache durch bestimmte
bewegungsabläufe können sie sich so
untereinander die entfernung von
futterquellen mitteilen außerdem können
sie über duftstoffe ihren geschmack und
durch geräusche kommunizieren wenn
bienen rechner wären hätten sie
definitiv die beste grafik karte
denn sie nehmen unglaubliche mengen an
bildern war pro sekunde können es bis zu
300 stück sein das liegt so er im
gaming-bereich zum vergleich menschen
schaffen etwa 25 bis 60 bilder pro
sekunde dafür haben bienen gleich zwei
augen arten die zwei großen
facettenaugen die man sofort erkennt und
zusätzlich noch punkt augen in der mitte
des kopfes sitzen drei von den
unbewegten punkt augen den sogenannten o
zellen mit denen die insekten zwischen
hell und dunkel unterscheiden können die
facettenaugen bestehen aus bis zu 8000
kleinen sechseckigen einzel augen die
heißen monate dienen und nehmen jeweils
einen bildpunkt waren diese bildpunkte
setzt das gehirn der biene dann zu einem
bild zusammen außerdem sagt man den
bienen ihren fleiß nicht nur nach sie
sind tatsächlich ausgesprochen emsig für
ein kilo honig fliegt anbieten von drei
bis fünf millionen blüten an und
bewältigt dabei eine strecke von etwa
100000 kilometer
diese flugstrecken schaffen sie dank
ihrer beeindruckenden flüge
die setzen bienen nicht nur zum fliegen
ein sondern auch um ihren bienenstock zu
erwärmen die durchscheinenden flüge
wirken zwar sehr fragil
doch sie sind durch die rippen und stege
die adern aussehen ausgesprochen stabil
das muster dieser adern ist bei allen
gleich und an ihren flügeln kann man
ihnen sogar ihr alter ansehen ältere
tiere haben in der regel ausgefranste
flügel ränder bienen sind übrigens zwei
flügler das heißt sie haben auf jeder
seite die einen fordern und einen hinter
flüge allerdings verhaken sich diese
beim flug ineinander so dass sie wie ein
flügel wirken um die schnellen flügel
bewegungen auszuführen haben bienen
starke flugmuskeln auf der brust das
typische bienen summen entsteht durch
luftbewegung der schnellen flügelschläge
eine normale honigbiene kann sogar bis
zu 30 kilometer pro stunde fliegen und
entfernt sich auch schon zehn kilometer
weit von ihrem bienenstock weg was am
flug der bienen auch sehr spannend ist
die insekten können auch rückwärts
fliegen das tun sie vor allem wenn sie
eine blüte umkreisen außerdem nutzen sie
ihre flügel auch um ihren bienenstock zu
temperieren
durch ein konstantes zittern mit der
muskulatur können sie den bienenstock im
winter erhitzen teilweise sogar auf über
35 grad wenn es im sommer zu warm wird
umschwirren die insekten den eingang des
bienenstocks und erzeugen dadurch einen
luftstrom der den bienenstock kühl zu
verhindern sie dass die wachs warben
schmelzen wenn es zu heiß wird neben
diesen funktionalen einsatz haben die
bienen eine ganz besondere
aerodynamische flug strategie die ein
amerikanisches forschungsteam genauer
unter die lupe genommen hat im jahr 1934
schlossen august mac nennen und andré
sonntag aus einer einfachen
mathematischen analyse das ist gar nicht
möglich sei dass bienen fliegen seitdem
sind bienen ein symbol dafür dass die
aerodynamische theorie die auf tiere
angewandt wird nicht ausreichend ist und
dass die natur der wissenschaft
anscheinend einen schritt bzw
einen flügelschlag voraus ist wenn es
nach den üblichen kriterien in der
biomechanik des insekten flugs geht nach
der die schlagfrequenz der vögel zunimmt
desto kleiner ein insekt ist schlagen
bieten eigentlich viel zu schnell mit
ihren vögeln sie schaffen 240 schläge
pro sekunde im vergleich die viel
kleinere fruchtfliege drosophila kommt
mit nur 200 schlägen pro sekunde aus um
dem auf den grund zu gehen hat michael
dickenson vom california institute of
technology
einige bienen im labor beobachtet
mithilfe einer
hochgeschwindigkeitskamera die 6000
bilder pro sekunde schießt konnten die
insekten in einem durchsichtigen kasten
genauer unter die lupe genommen werden
mit drei dieser kameras wurden die
bieten gleichzeitig aus verschiedenen
richtungen gefilmt so konnte man
aufnehmen wie sie im dreidimensionalen
raum fliegen und so wurde festgehalten
wie sie vom blüte abheben und in den
schwebeflug geben ein spezielles
computerprogramm verfolgte dann
ihre markante punkte der bienen anatomie
in jeder einzelaufnahmen und so wurde
ein exaktes bewegungsmuster der bienen
flügel im raum erfasst so lässt sich
detailliert nachverfolgen wie die
insekten fliegen um zusätzlich zu
verstehen welche aerodynamischen kräfte
beim bienenflug zum einsatz kommt hat
das forschungsteam eine unglaubliche und
sehr aufwendige apparatur entwickelt ein
riesiges roboter insekt das befindet
sich in einem tank der mit drei tonnen
mineralöl gefüllt ist der roboter wurde
dann mit den bewegungsdaten aus den
bienen aufnahmen gefüttert und konnte
dadurch exakt so mit seinen flügeln
schlagen wie es die bienen tun die
forschenden konnten dadurch die kräfte
messen die beim flug der insekten zum
einsatz kommen und analysieren wie die
biene fliegt und sich durch die luft
navigiert das ergebnis ist absolut
erstaunlich die hohe flügelschlag
frequenz der tiere wird an einer anderen
stelle wieder ausgeglichen
die schlag amplitude also der winkel mit
dem die flügel rauf und runter bewegt
werden beträgt bei den bienen und etwa
90 grad das sae aerodynamik weniger
effizient als anschlag mit einer hohen
amplitude bei dem weit ausgeholt wird
zumindest im schwebeflug die meisten
fliegenden insekten schlagen ihre flügel
in viel größeren schlägen mit bürgern
von 145 bis 165 grad und um die bienen
nicht nur schweben sondern auch bei der
arbeit zu beobachten haben die
forschenden einen kniff angewandt die
bienen wurden sozusagen manipuliert
indem der stickstoff der normalerweise
80 prozent der atemluft ausmacht im
versuch behälter durch helium ersetzt
wurde den tieren bleibt dadurch noch
genügend sauerstoff aber die luft hat
eine sehr viel geringere dichte
dadurch müssten die insekten deutlich
härter arbeiten um zu fliegen das ist in
etwa so als würde man sie auf einem sehr
hohen berg fliegen lassen oder ihnen ein
gewicht anhängen
die umstellung stellte tatsächlich kein
problem für die tiere da der effekt war
dass sie ihre schnelle schlagfrequenz
beibehalten haben je geringer der
luftwiderstand und damit je höher die
zusätzlichen las wurde desto stärker
vergrößerten die bienen den schlag
winkel
so haben sie ihre aerodynamische
leistung gesteigert und sich den neuen
gegebenheiten angepasst zu diesem
verhalten hat das forschungsteam mehrere
theorien
eine davon hängt mit der sehr speziellen
ökologie von bienen
zusammen um pollen und nektar zum stopp
transportieren zu können müssen sie
enorm schwere lasten transportieren
können
dadurch dass sie im schweben eher
ineffizient fliegen ihre flügelschläge
unter belastung aber sehr effizient
einsetzen haben sie an größeren
dynamischen spielraum
mit dem können sie sich bei bedarf in
einen kleinen lasten transporter
verwandeln die andere theorie ist dass
bienen im verlauf der evolution eine
andere art von flugmuskeln entwickelt
haben als etwa fliegen ihr muskel typ
funktioniert möglicherweise erst bei
hohen schlag frequenzen und hohen
temperaturen optimal und so hat sich die
besondere aerodynamische strategie der
bienen entwickelt diese erkenntnisse
können ingenieuren helfen rotierenden
propeller oder stabilere und wendigeren
flugzeuge zu konstruieren dieses
wunderwerk der natur lässt sich mit den
richtigen treffen sogar gut mit einer
kamera einfangen selbst wenn man keine
hochgeschwindigkeitskamera hat wie die
forschenden im labor für beeindruckende
fotos von fliegenden insekten braucht
man vor allem geduld damit man den
richtigen moment erwischt dann hat man
mit dem serienbildmodus für eine
schnelle bildfolge gute chancen die
bienen beim anflug auf ihren stock oder
eine blüte einzufangen und heutige
kameras bieten da ja immer mehr
möglichkeiten wie genau das geht erfahrt
ihr in der aktuellen cd fotografie extra
und als klicks um zuschauer und
zuschauerinnen bekommt ihr jetzt sogar
eine digitale ausgabe gratis mit vielen
profitipps fundierten workshops und
spannenden auto anleitung außerdem
findet ihr dank der umfangreichen als
ihr könnt das sehen übrigens dank der
umfangreichen produkttests von kameras
objektive und fotozubehör auf jeden fall
das richtige equipment probiert es aus
es kostet nichts alles was er tun dafür
tun muss ist hier auf den link zu
klicken wenn er funktioniert also beim
letzten mal gab es da ein bisschen
probleme oder die aktion hier unten in
der video beschreibung an kriegt also
bis dann bleibt dran